IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Hi everyone,
I'm Ibrahim Ulukaya from
YouTube API Developers Relations
team joining you
today from New York studios.
And today, we'll talk
about getting help
with YouTube APIs.
Either you're just a new
developer starting to develop
with YouTube APIs, or you
are already building the
applications and you just want
to create a new functionality
and you're having
some problems.
You may need some help.
And we'll definitely help you.
We're just trying to
present the best
ways to get that help.
So I will go over the four
different ways to get help.
I'll start with a demo.
I'll start with YouTube
developer documentation.
I'll talk about today the
developer documentation first,
and our API blog second, Stack
Overflow third, and the last
one using the issue tracker.
Let's get started.
Let's talk about the developer
documentation.
So developer documentation is
the site map on the left side.
And let's say that you're having
a problem with version
three, and you're trying to
find the functionality.
In getting started, you'll see
some help with adjusting your
application, implementing
the OAuth2 [INAUDIBLE]
methods, or getting the client
libraries to start developing.
In Guides, you will see how to
upload a video of it, the code
samples, or doing it [INAUDIBLE]
upload, as well as
there will be some technical
documentations like the
difference between the channel
IDs versus user names and the
Google+ IDs.
Or you can be having some
problems, and you want to
actually migrate from client
login to OAuth2 some technical
documentation here as well.
Also, you have a detailed
documentation on
the reference site.
You'll see all the resources
here like video, channels,
playlists, search, thumbnails.
And let's think that
you actually
want to list the channels.
You want to actually get some
information about a
channel of a user.
And you actually want to use
the list method call.
Here, you will see all the
required parameters, the
request itself, the filters,
some optional parameters.
And you'll see it shows the
response here, how the
response will look like.
You'll see the response will
be a channel resource.
You'll see all the error codes
and why they could be
happening, as well as at the
end, you will see an API
explorer, which you can actually
just plug in your
parameters and try the actual
code, the actual
functionality.
As I mentioned earlier,
it will return
that channel resource.
And in the channel resource in
the response, you can actually
see what you can get back.
You can get the likes, the
uploads, playlists, or you can
get some statistics--
and a lot of information will
be available here--
and the formats of the responses
and the other
parameters, as well as the
attributes depending on that,
attached on that.
So developer documentation is
really helpful for this.
You can even search developer
documentation with additional
problems like channels.
You can actually go to
documentation from there.
Or you can just use the site map
on the left side, the left
navigation.
The second resource
is the API blog.
In API Blog, we usually blog
about the new things about use
of API, what's changing, what
is new, and all the other--
[INAUDIBLE]
could be even a change on the
developer documentation or
something else.
And they are really helpful.
You will get the most
updated information.
So I really suggest you to
subscribe to RSS feeds and get
the updated documentation
right away.
And here, you'll see the
latest documentation in
apiblog.youtube.com.
You will see all the latest
challenges or the differences,
the latest updates
on YouTube APIs.
You can do a search.
So today, actually, I want
to talk about [INAUDIBLE]
featured requests or get more
help, like one to one help
from the YouTube APIs.
And from there, we'll
actually use Stack
Overflow of an issue tracker.
So I will actually search for
a Stack Overflow blog.
And September 14, 2012, we
actually issued a blog about
that talking about that
we are not using
Google Groups anymore.
But instead, we are using the
Stack Overflow for the coding
questions as the issue tracker
for files, bugs, and featured
reports, featured requests.
So Stack Overflow is a really
nice community to ask the
questions and get answers
from peer to peer.
In that case, you can
actually just--
all you need to use,
the YouTube-API.
So we can track off all the
questions about YouTube API.
And we can get the answers
right away.
So far, we are actually trying
our best to get all the
questions answered over there.
You will get your questions
answered really fast.
Even before asking a new
question, you can just search
for another question.
Or you are trying to get the
thumbnail links, maybe.
You actually use YouTube
API tag and ask for the
thumbnails.
Here, you will have already an
answer about the thumbnails.
And you just go and just use
the answer over there.
Or if your question is not
over there, you can just
create a new question.
If you're not going to use the
search engine, or you are
just-- even for faster response,
you can actually
just use a Google search engine
and just try to find
your question.
I use always these kinds
of questions.
I use YouTube API tag.
It's a YouTube API question.
And then I say, how
to set thumbnails.
Maybe my question is
about [INAUDIBLE]
PHP.
I'm maybe looking for a PHP
answer, PHP coding answer.
And here, I can actually see
that the thumbnail set
operation, the method is
already here from the
developer documentation.
All ready, people ask
about the similar
questions of Stack Overflow.
As far as I can see here, I
can just click the Stack
Overflow questioning here.
And it will actually
take me to the
Stack Overflow question.
Or someone already asked about
how to set the custom
thumbnails for videos.
And there's a response
already here.
And they agreed on that.
So I can use the
same response.
Or if there's not enough, I
can actually create more
comments at the end
or ask another
question from Stack Overflow.
But I will need to mention
that Stack Overflow is a
community to ask coding
questions.
So if your problem is more
about YouTube's own thing
about how the videos are
handled, how the search is
handed, or something, not about
API or not coding, then
Stack Overflow is not a good
platform for that one.
And if you have--
maybe you're already trying
something, and you found the
bug, or maybe the server's not
responding for your method,
and you want actually
[INAUDIBLE], so rather than
creating a question in Stack
Overflow, we highly recommend
you to use the issue tracker.
It's under
code.google.com/p/g.issues
[INAUDIBLE] issues.
It's the open public issue
tracker that you can actually
find your other issues
over there.
Or you can create a new issue
or a featured request.
To find the YouTube issues,
you can actually use
api:youtube.
And it will actually go through
and find all the
YouTube API problems,
YouTube API issues.
Maybe you're adding some issue
with the [INAUDIBLE], and you
see it's already filed here,
so we don't need to create
another issue.
Rather than that, you'd actually
rather just go and
star this issue.
You can star this issue, or
you can create your own
problem maybe under
the same topic.
So you will actually be notified
when this issue is
fixed, or someone else had a
similar problem or found a
different solution.
Rather than creating a new one,
that's really helpful.
And it's also helpful for us,
because we can actually track
how many people are
having this issue.
And if the issue's really
critical or the issue's really
valid that so many people
already filed this issue, or
this featured request is
really on high demand--
so they can prioritize things
way easier if you rather than
creating a [INAUDIBLE]
issues just going to
[INAUDIBLE], write your own
stuff or star this issue.
So we highly suggest people to
use for their featured request
or bug filing to use the
g.issue tracker.
And in the blog itself,
you'll see the only
the templates here--
either Stack Overflow templates
that will create a
Stack Overflow question or that
will create a template
for you, a YouTube [INAUDIBLE]
report which will show you
which API was affected off
that, or the steps to
reproduce the issue.
So you can say that, oh, I used
this API method call.
My code was like this.
And it returned to
me like this.
Or when you did these
parameters, the
response was like that.
So you can easily produce
the issue and it can
help you way faster.
Or you may just want to actually
create a featured
request using another
template here--
filing your featured request.
And you will see that you
create a request and the
reason for this feature,
how it can help you,
and things like that.
You can even list the existing
[INAUDIBLE].
We always ask you to check the
list of existing [INAUDIBLE]
before filing a duplicate
request.
So you just create this one.
You actually click the
list of open APIs.
As you see, it will
actually check the
label dash API YouTube.
Or you can just do the
api:youtube as well.
So today, we actually went over
the four different ways
of getting help.
The first one was going to
developer.google.com/youtube
or developer documentation.
The second one was API Blog
using the apiblog.youbue.com.
The third one was asking a
call-in question on Stack
Overflow and getting peer to
peer help or getting help from
us direct from here.
Or if it was a server issue, if
it was any issue, like you
want to file a bug or create a
feature request, you can just
use the g.issue tracker.
So these are the things
that actually I
want to go over today.
And as the last thing, I want
to mention that as developer
relations team, we
are hiring almost
everywhere around the world.
And you go into
developers.google.com/jobs.
You will see all the open
positions as well as
descriptions of all the
available jobs.
And make a comment, just check
it out, and maybe if there's
something for you.
That was all the things that
I want to talk about today.
Thanks for joining me, Ibrahim
Ulukaya from New York.